and jane campion she uh allowed you to
kind of stay in character but more than
that she encouraged you to kind of live
your life in the way that he might have
lived very very much sean i mean i sort
of went off to to dude basically she was
very very secure about all the things i
was insecure about but she said look
whatever you need to sort of feel that
you have ownership of this very
different lived experience to your own
let us know and i went um
okay uh the banjo horse riding whittling
whistling i'm angry taxidermy i mean
this man is
masterful he's a brilliant craftsman
with his hands he lives in this very
brutal masculine world but he has great
sensitivity and craftsmanship about him
which is a kind of clue to the inner
turmoil of his true self as well but
to feel that and experience that i went
off to montana for a couple of months to
to learn about what it's like to live on
a ranch and perform all the things you
see in the film
was it the ranch you didn't wash or was
it on the set no it was it was it was in
the first couple of weeks of rehearsal
in new zealand and you know this
character wears his work on him with
great pride the mud the grime the sweat
and the blood and uh
he doesn't wash reportedly in the book
for sort of three or four months at a
time wow yeah i mean he does spend most
of his time outdoors so maybe the wind
is sort of
carrying it away but when you haven't
experienced that in the 21st century
where we're all quite clean and this is
by the way just before a pandemic broke
out where we're told to wash our hands
so i'm singing happy birthday twice it's
a very odd character to be playing
someone who just refuses to watch and
yet you know that was a very important
part of trying to authenticate who this
person was and just feel that on my skin
and then and then and then jane really
pulled the rug under me by saying oh
let's go out for sushi and i was like no
come on in a rehearsal room it's fine
but now you want me to go out into the
world with this bio hazard of a funk
around me just like speaking of
something very odd
there are people out there in the world
who really want to know what i smell
like and i'm sort of a little bit
self-conscious about that
daisy this is this yeah that daisy is
going to experience you'll get this yeah
yeah
that's why the lock down was a good
thing
but yeah i was out there sort of having
sushi and feeling very very
self-conscious when the waiter just said
they're observed
[Music]
you